why don't we just do a buddy cop movie
about Christian Grey and it's cop I feel
like you're not focused I have
unfortunately Ricky she's a great Lois
we tried to watch the movie and he fell
asleep I was curious
it's like a national phenomenon I'm
gonna try not to you know bring my
preconceived ideas to how it's gonna be
to this I think will be moments Lobby
turned down oh wow Showtime grey absent
mindedly she wipes a crumb from the
corner of her lips and into her mouth
and sucks on her finger my [ __ ] twitches
in response if your dick is twitching
you should see a doctor she has a fresh
wholesome fragrance that reminds me of
my grandfather's apple orchard imagine
your grandfather's apple orchard in an
erotic book you have going into a creepy
realm it occurs to me that I could
refine her motor skills with the aid of
a riding crop we're [ __ ] beat harder
against the bathroom door she's mine
I bury myself in her and she dead wait
hold on the feel of her her smell her
taste fisting my hand in her hair
holding her in place how do you fist
your hand someone's hair her sharp
intake of breath is music to my dick
does it also seem like this book is
written by like a fifth grader was away
by a fifth grader are you getting on
back there what do you mean yeah
absolutely if you want me to act like
Christian Grey's out I was totally
kidding an image of her shackle to my
bed Pio gingerroot inserted in her ah so
she can clutch her butt up I don't know
what a ginger root is but you don't put
that in someone's butt she does with a
huge [ __ ] tightening grin what an
adjective
do you like Rhydian like a more sexual
way can I open my eyes
they wrapped around her she looks
radiant my [ __ ] agrees that was like
kind of sweetened nice for a little bit
there and then he's just like my [ __ ]
this there are three people in this
relationship
Gregg her and lifting my hips I grab my
[ __ ] I want you to become well
acquainted on first-name terms you don't
like being on a first-name basis with my
[ __ ] excuse me I don't agree with it
don't look at me like I don't agree with
him what do i do - chill out sailing
flying testing the limits of attractive
brunettes like her and bringing him to
heel what I get from this is that she's
an object and he owns her her ass will
need training I'm going to make you [ __ ]
like a freight it's elaborate well
because it's a double entendre she's
working on many different levels the
descriptions in this book makes sex not
fun I was expecting you to have a little
bit more fluff I don't know how women
could read this and he want their own
version of this guy does capture a man's
point of view because a lot of men do
name their penises I don't think that's
a real thing those words aren't just
bouncing around in my head consistently
oh my god this is a pretty good grilled
cheese my [ __ ] agrees that doesn't
happen
I think the point in the series is not
like she changes him if they get to move
on to like the fifth book I think we'll
see a transformation maybe he'll like
have some feelings and they won't all be
about his [ __ ] I'm not gonna read any
more this I might
[Music]
alright I'm gonna go wash my mouth out
with soap